[Música]
bienvenidos 2 a 5 minutos con las
puertas de los comicios en mexico este
próximo 6 de junio para elegir a 15
gobernadores y 500 legisladores
federales hay temor en la población
dados los crecientes casos de
ejecuciones secuestros y amenazas a
candidatos según la firma et elec que en
lo que va del proceso electorales dice
que se suman en 2021 unos 88 asesinatos
políticos incluyendo 14 candidatos y 34
aspirantes a sillas gubernamentales
vamos a conversar con rubén salazar
director de et el ex consultores que
realizó el indicador de violencia
política en mexico rubén es bienvenido a
france24 y esto es gravísimo la
participación política en un país y sus
líderes son víctimas de una ola de
violencia frontal como llegaron a este
extremo y en qué momento se salió tanto
de control el crimen y con un presidente
que se dice abanderado contra la
corrupción
tener muy buenos días muchas gracias por
la invitación pues si lo que priva en
estos hechos de violencia en contra de
políticos y candidatos lamentablemente
es la impunidad
nosotros en electa hace tres años
registramos por ejemplo 152 políticos
asesinados de los cuales 48 eran tanto
aspirantes como candidatos a diversos
puestos de elección se consideró
entonces la selección la más violenta
desde el año 2000 por lo menos en esta
elección como bien dices tenemos 88
políticos han sido asesinados en los
cuales 34 son tanto aspirantes como
candidatos a diversos puestos el 90% de
estas víctimas pero tenemos en el ámbito
municipal de gobierno es ahí en donde
tenemos el problema sobre todo puestos
que tienen que ver con cargos de
alcaldías de regidurías y de
sindicaturas es importante señalar que
como que en esta cifra de 88 políticos
del 75 por ciento eran opositores a los
32 gobiernos estatales me parece un dato
muy relevante y de los 34 aspirantes por
ejemplo 29 que buscaban cargos
municipales de estos 29 el 89 por ciento
a su vez eran opositores a los alcalde
de los municipios en donde pensaban
gobernar estamos hablando de un problema
que está focalizado en el ámbito
municipal no ha alcanzado todavía las
grandes esferas de la política de a
nivel estatal ni acceder
- en el nivel federal mire precisamente
hay investigaciones que están en curso
pero a estas alturas todavía no hay
detenidos que se puede esperar porque
aquí hay un caso de corrupción que se ve
estructural el caso más reciente fue el
de alma rosa barragán santiago la
candidata del movimiento ciudadano a la
presidencia de moroleón
lamentablemente debido a la lentitud de
las averiguaciones lo que prueba en
todos estos casos históricamente es la
impunidad muy pocos casos se resuelven
de hecho desde el año 2000 a 2021 en los
últimos 21 años de elecciones en nuestro
país tenemos un registro de 142
aspirantes y candidatos asesinados el
mayor relevancia quizá haya sido el
candidato a la gubernatura de tamaulipas
asesinado en 2010 y muy pocos de estos
casos son investigados no tenemos una
estadística oficial por ejemplo que nos
hable de los móviles quienes fueron los
autores intelectuales o materiales y
finalmente cuando se asesina un
candidato hay alguien que se está
beneficiando política y electoralmente
es una obligación de las autoridades
mexicanas puedes investigar a fondo
estos casos para hacer justicia sólo en
la parte penal sino también en la parte
electoral claro y es que estaríamos
hablando entonces de corrupción también
a esos niveles de los entes que están
obligados a investigar este tipo de
crímenes cuál es el mensaje que esto le
deja a los votantes y ya la política
mexicana que tanto requiere de un
sacudón y peor aún cuál es el mensaje
que esto deja a las mujeres que han sido
también víctimas en
parte de estos crímenes
pues el mensaje precisamente es que el
costo del delito es muy bajo que
cualquiera en este país puede amenazar
puede extorsionar puede secuestrar o
incluso asesinar a un político sin
consecuencia alguna entonces eso es muy
importante y muy muy relevante para el
futuro de nuestra democracia impedir que
estas conductas delictivas en contra de
la política y en contra de la democracia
y finalmente en contra de la ciudadanía
y de los electores persistan porque si
prevemos un ambiente de polarización
política mayor de cara a los comicios
presidenciales del 2024
pues mire muchísimas gracias a ustedes
por la información que nos brinda y que
podremos ampliar también en france 24
punto com y recordarles a nuestros
televidentes muchos de los candidatos y
candidatas que murieron no contaban con
personal de seguridad y el gobierno dice
que nunca fue notificado de esto además
los ataques predominan como dijo nuestro
invitado contra opositores a gobiernos
estatales y al gobierno federal fueron
atacados candidatos del pan pri morena
pr de independientes hasta aquí cinco
minutos con nos sigan con nosotros en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]